[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير وانا ميسون
ويهد هذه اخبار الساعه نبدا بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
لاوكرانيا بالقول انه امر غير مستبعد شرط
ان لا يضعف جيوشنا
مبعوث امريكا
بعد قصير اسلحه تابع له
واخرجهم دموي الكبير يستهدف مسجدا في
بيشاور وطالبان باكستان تنفيذلوعها
بالتفجير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
واثناء لقاء جماعه براسه وزراء هولندا
ماركروتا قال ان امر ارسال طائرات مقاتله
الى اوكرانيا غير مستبعد وانا لا شيء
ممنوع مكروه اشار ايضا الى ان دعم باريس
لاوكرانيا بالمقاتلات يجب ان لا يضعف
الجيش الفرنسي كما لا ينبغي استخدام
الاسلحه التي ترسل لاوكرانيا في ضرب
الاراضي الروسيه هذا مشاهدينا تمتلك فرنسا
طائره عسكريه مقاتله طائره رفعل هي مقاتله
متعدده المهام مصممه لاداء التفوق الجوي
والاعتراض والاستطلاع الجوي والدعم الارضي
والضربات العميقه والضاربات المضاده للسفن
ومهام الردع النوويه كما تمتلك طائرات
نقاتله من طراز ميراج التي صممت كان
مقاتله خفيفه لصالح القوات الجويه
الفرنسيه وهي الان تخدم في ثماني دول وصنع
منها اكثر من 600 قطعه
للمزيد ينضم اليه من باريس مراسل العربيه
حسين قنيبر حسين اهلا بك معنا في اي اطار
يمكن ان نضع تصريحات الرئيس نكرون بعدم
استبعاد ارسال مقاتلات الى اوكرانيا
في اطار الرغبه الفرنسيه المتزايده في
التاكيد على ان باريس لن تتردد في تقديم
كل المعدات التي يمكن ان تمكن اكرانيا من
تعزيز جهدها في المقاومه وفي حمايه
اراضيها كما كرر المسؤولون الفرنسيون
مرارا وخصوصا خلال اللقاء الذي كان شارع
في الثاني والعشرين من هذا الشهر بين
الرئيس الفرنسي والمستشار الالماني كان
اكد مكرونه ما عاد واكده اليوم خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك مع ماركه رئيس
الوزراء الهولندي فرنسي
قبل ارسال المعدات العسكريه الى اوكرانيه
اولا ان لا تكون خطوه ارسال اي نوع من
الاسلحه تصعيديه بمعنى الا تماس الطائرات
المقاتله او الدبابات الاراضي الروسيه وان
يتركز دورها على التحقيق التعزيز جهد
اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها وفي حمايه
اراضيها وتعزيز مقاومتها ثانيا يجب ان
يكون ارسال المعدات العسكريه مفيده
لاوكرانيا بمعنى ان يحصل بعد تاهيل وتدريب
الجنود الاوكرانيين على كيفيه استخدام
الارسلحه المرسله اليهم وكيفيه صيانتها
اذا تعطلت المعيار الثالث الا يؤثر ما
ترسله فرنسا من معدات عسكريه على قدرات
الجيش الفرنسي الدفاعيه
كل شيء ممنوع عنه الرئيس بكبر فرنسا لماذا
دائما تخاف من اضعاف الجيش دائما تشترط
بانها ترسل مقاتلات او ترس الاسلحه ولكن
اهم شيء ان لا يضعف الجيش
الفرنسي لماذا تتخوف في الدائم
سؤالك مشروع لان الامر يبدو محيرا للمراقب
من بعيد بالفعل ميسون لكن الواقع ان فرنسا
بدات ومنذ انتهاء الحرب البارده بالتخلص
من قسم كبير من مخزونها العسكري التجنبا
لنفقات صيانته وخصوصا بدءا من العام
2007 تزايد التخلص من هذا المخزون العسكري
خصوصا مع الازمه الاقتصاديه في اوروبا عام
2008 لاننا فقط صيانه هذا المخزون العسكري
تبدو كبيره على سبيل المثال دبابات الكلير
الفرنسيه القتاليه الثقيله التي يبلغ
ثمنها حوالي ثمانيه ملايين يورو تبلغ كلفه
صيانتها سنويا ربع مليون يورو من هنا كان
الاتجاه الفرنسي الى التخلص من جزء من
المخزون العسكري فباع باريس او فكك قسما
كبيرا منه لانه لم يكن احد يتخيل ان تقع
حرب في اوروبا على شكل وبعنف الحرب الى في
اوكرانيا مع ذلك ما زالت فرنسا مستعده
لارسال المعدات العسكريه الى اوكرانيا غدا
سيستقبل الرئيس ماكرون وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اولكسي رزني كوف الذي سيلتقي
ايضا لنظيره الفرنسي ايرزني كوف سيلتقي
بيه سباستيان لقرني وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
قبل هذه الخطوات كانت فرنسا ارسلت مدافع
سيزار 18 مدفعا كما ارسلت همم مصفحات
خفيفه
واستعدت لان ترسل همم دبابات خفيفه من
طراز ام اكس ترسلها خلال فتره شهرين كما
ارسلت صواريخ للدفاع الجوي من طراز
ميسترال وايضا الغام مضاد للدروع
والصواريخ مضاده للدروع من طراز شكرا لك
حسين على كل هذه المعلومات على كل هذه
التفاصيل
قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني بانوال السنه
الدبابات البريطانيه ستصل الى الخطوط
الاماميه لاوكرانيا قبيله فصل الصيف نتابع
يبدا بالتدريب فردي ثم التدريب على
الدبابات ثم التدريب على القتال كتشكيل ما
يمكنني قوله سيكون تسليم في بدايه الصيف
او في شهر مايو او ربما سيتزامل مع عيد
الفصحى في شهر ابريل
[موسيقى]
خلال الاتصال العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين كما اتفق على تطويرها في عدد من
المشاكل
[موسيقى]
رغم ان الغربه بات على قبه الاستعداد
لمساعده اوكرانيا اكثر واكثر خصوصا عسكريا
وبالاسلحه الثقيله لكن المستشاره الالماني
اولاب شغل وبعد موافقه بلاده على تزويد
اوكرانيا بالدبابات جددت تاكيد على ان
بلاده لن ترسل طائره مقاتله الى اوكرانيا
وذلك بعد ان كثفت كاف دعوتها للغرب من اجل
تسليمها اسلحه اكثر تطورا اما حلف الناتو
من الجهه الاخرى من العالم
امينو عام الحلف كوريا الجنوبيه الى تكثيف
مساعدتها العسكريه لاوكرانيا مقترحا عليها
مراجعه سياستها المتمثله بعدم تسليح
الدولي المتحركه
[موسيقى]
وقفي دار الاستمرار المعارك في مختلف
المدن الاوكرانيه كشف المدعي العام
الاوكراني تسجيله اكثر من 66,000 جريمه
اضافيه في البلاد منذ بدا روسيا حربها على
بلاده وا يتزايدوا عدد الجرائم المسجله
بالمئات كل يوم مع انتشار المحققين في
المناطق التي استعادها الاوكرانيون من
الروس وفق صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه
كما افادت الصحيفه بان الجرائم تتراوحو
بين طريقه الممتلكات الى التعذيب والقتل
والاغتصاب وترحيل الاطفال الاوكرانيين الى
روسيا وضربات الصاروخيه التي استهدفت
البنيه التحتيه الاخرانيه
[موسيقى]
بولس جونسون وبعيدا عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
ولكن ليس بعيدا عن بوتن يروي رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني السابق في وثائقي ستبثه هيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه ان الرئيس الروسي
الذيب بوتين هدده بشكل من الاشكال قبل
الحرب في اوكرانيا قائلا له بصاروخ
سيستغرق الامر دقيقه واحده في المقابل
نافع الكريم لنت تلك الاتهامات على لسان
المتحدث باسمه
الذي قال ان تصريحات جونسون غير صحيحه
وانها كذب
[موسيقى]
والان الى تطورات الملف الايراني حيث قلم
ببطوله الامريكيه الخاص الى سهران روبرت
مالي في مقابله مع اذاعه بي بي سي واشنطن
لن تتردد باتخاذ اي خطوه لوقف سلوك ايران
العدواني اذا فشل الحوار كما اضاف مالي ان
الخيار العسكري مع ايران مطروح اذا فشل
المسار الدبلوماسيه تحدث المبعوث
الامريكيه الخاص الى سهران ايضا عن ان
ايران قريبه من امتلاك ما يكفي من
اليورانيوم لصناعه قنبله النوويه
[موسيقى]
الان الى جوله وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطونيو بلينكن الى الشرق الاوسط حيث
التقى في تل ابيب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين الثانيه
اللقاء ان اي شيء بعيد عن حل الدولتين يضر
بان اسرائيل وان على الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين اتخاذا خطوات فوريه للحد من
التصعيد ووقفه
بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين والملف النووي
الايراني شكلات طبق الساخنه على مائده
الحوار بين رئيس الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
وصانعي القرار في اسرائيل
كل ما بيسعها لمن ايران من امتلاك سلاح
النووي ونحن مصممون على تنفيذ هذه السياسه
في الوقت الذي نجح نتنياه فيه لسنوات في
تهميش الموضوع الفلسطيني اعاده تصعيده في
ظل حكومه تشمل وزراء متطرفين الى الواجهه
وتاتي زياره رام الله كما مسؤولين
امريكيين اخرين رساله لاسرائيل بان توسيع
دائره التطبيع بين اسرائيل ودول المنطقه
وحتى مواجهه ايران باتت مرتبطه بعدم تدمير
حل دولتين
تنفيذ رؤيه حل الدولتين وكما قلت لرئيس
الوزراء فان اي شيء يبعدنا عن هذه الرؤيه
هو بمفهومنا يمس بامن اسرائيل على المدى
البعيد
وبهويتنا كدوله يهوديه ديمقراطيه
اللافته ان زياره بلنك الى جانب مدير
السياحي الموجود في اسرائيل تزامنت مع شني
ثلاث غارات متفرقه على اهداف داخل ايران
وفي الاقليم طالت القدرات البالستيه وسلاح
المسيره بعيدا عن الكلام الدبلوماسي
الامريكي والاسرائيلي فان ارث التوتر في
العلاقه بين نتنياهو اداره بايدين يلقي
بظلالها على الحوار الامريكي الاسرائيلي
مع الحكومه الجديده ايضا واشنطن نقلت
قلقها مرتين مرتين من الملف الفلسطينيه
والانفجار الحاصل ومره ثانيه من الملف
الايراني والخشيه من مفاجات الاسرائيليه
زياد حلب العربيه القدس
وعلى ضوئي تصاعد التطورات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل توفي شاب فلسطيني
متاثرا باصابته برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه
في مدينه الخليل حسب ما اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه وبذلك يرتفع عدد الفلسطينيين
الذين قتلوا في الضفه الغربيه خلال هذا
الشهر الى 35 بينهم مدنيون وبعضهم قصار
ومسلحون واشخاص نفذوا هجمات فيما قتل في
نفس الفتره سته مدنيين اسرائيليين بينهم
قصر اضافه الى مواطن اوكرانيا وفي السياق
حمل رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد اشتياق
اسرائيل المسؤوليه الكامله والمباشره عن
التصعيد الحاصل في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
مطالبا دول العالم في مستهل جلسه الحكومه
اليوم الى اذان تصريحات وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الداعيه لحمل السلاح ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
يحمل مجلس الوزراء حكومه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه الكامله والمباشره عن تصعيد
عدوانها وانتهاكاتها وشرائمها اليوميه ضد
ابناء شعبنا في مخيم جنين الصامت ومدينه
القدس المحتله وجميع المدن والبلدات
والقرى والمخيمات التي تتعرض لاعتداءات
جنود الاحتلال والمستوطنين كان اخرها صباح
اليوم استشهاد الشاب نسيم ابو فوده في
مدينه الخليل
اهلا بكم معك ابرز ما حصل اليوم ابرز هذه
اللقاءات وابرز التصريحات
اهلا بك ميسون طبعا وزير الخارجيه اعلن من
خلال من اكثر من تصريح سواء كان عندما وصل
الى تل ابيب او عندما التقى معنى ثنياهو
او مع وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي وفي
اللقاء الاخير الذي جمعهم مع الرئيس
الاسرائيلي طلب من الجانبين التهدئه لا
تريد الولايات المتحده اي تصعيد على
الاطلاق وطبعا اليوم صباح اليوم في
القاهره انا كنت سالته بالنسبه للاجراءات
التي تتخذها الحكومه الاسرائيليه والتي
حدد بها نتنياهو بانه سيقوم بابعاد عائلات
الفلسطينيين الذين يقومون بهذه العمليات
طبعا هدم البيوت مستمر منذ فتره طويله هذا
هو عقاب جماعي للفلسطينيين وهو انتهاك
للقانون الدولي ومن هنا اعتقد بان لينكن
ليس بالرسائل المعلنه امام الاعلام لكن
بالحوار الخاص قال لاسرائيل بشكل واضح
بانه لا يريد اي تصعيد على الاطلاق وهو
مرتبط ايضا بالملف الايراني ليس فقط
بالملف الفلسطيني لانه كما تعرفين اليوم
نتنياهو كان تتحدث على اهم اهم اكبر تهديد
لاسرائيل هو التهديد الايراني وبالتالي
اذا اراد ان يكون هناك ضوء اخضر من
الولايات المتحده لاي عمليات يجب ان يكون
هناك على الاقل هدوء في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وطبعا الاداره تريد ان تحافظ
نوعا ما على هذا الهدوء حتى تستطيع ان
ربما تخطي خطوات او صغيره جدا مثل الحبو
هي في الواقع ليست همم بخطوات كبيره لانه
كما تعرفين على الاداره لا تريد ان ترغب
في تفعيل همم المفاوضات بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين لانه الظروف غير مواتيه على
الاطلاق لكن العدد الكبير من الفلسطينيين
كما ذكرتي قبل قليل ميسون 35 فلسطين قلت
له في هذا الشهر همم واحده يعني هذا يعني
بان العنف يتزايد بشكل كبير وبالتالي
الاداره قلقه حتى قبل ان يصل همم بنكن الى
هنا الى القدس كانت وزيره الخارجيه تتحدث
دوما عن التهدئه وعن عدم التصعيد وعدم
اتخاذ خط يمكن ان تقيد تقود حل الدولتين
لكن ما رايناه في الايام الاخيره طبعا كان
بمثابه ربما استقبال اذا اردتي لي استقبال
واقعه لبنكن لانه الوضع طالما لا يكون
هناك اطار تفاوض حقيقي الوضع سيستمر ويمكن
ان يتدهور في اي لحظه ويمكن حتى الحديث
البعض يتحدث عن انتفاضه ثالثه رغم
استبعاده حاليا لانه اعتقد بان الولايات
المتحده ستمارس ضغوط قويه جدا على اسرائيل
وعلى حكومه يعني
نذهب الى عبد الحفيظ لنعرف منه ماذا ننتظر
عبد الحفيظ بلقاءات الغد وحل الدولتين
التي تحدث عنه ابنكن في الايام الماضيه هل
هو كافي بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
يعني من جانب تشعر السلطه الفلسطينيه لا
يمكن اخفاء السعاده التي تشعر بها يعني
وخصوصا ان هناك ثلاث زيارات من العيار
الثقيل زيارات امريكيه الى رام الله خلال
يعني الاسابيع الماضيه مستشار الامن
القومي مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
السي اييه والان وزير الخارجيه وبالتالي
هذا ينهي القطيعه التي كانت مع اداره
ترامب في الفتره السابقه هناك عوده
العلاقات بين السلطه الفلسطينيه والاداره
الامريكيه على طاوله الاجتماع هناك عند
الطلبات فلسطينيه سوف تطرح على وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه لعل اهمها هي ان الضغط
على اسرائيل اللي همم سلسله العقوبات التي
اتخذتها الحكومه الاسرائيليه بحق السلطه
الفلسطينيه بدايه هذا الشهر وتحديدا
المصادره اموال المقاصه ومعاقبه الشخصيات
الرسميه وغيرها من الاجراءات ايضا تريد
السلطه الفلسطينيه من الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه ان توفي بعوداتها وخصوصا موضوع
اعاده فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس
الشرقيه وايضا فتح
كاتب منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه في واشنطن
همم هذا من الجانب الامريكي تريد منها
ايضا ان تضغط على اسرائيل لوقف الاجراءات
احاديه الجانب التي يتصفها السلطه
الفلسطينيه بانها دمار لحل الدولتين
وخصوصا موضوع الاستيطان الكبير في الضفه
الغربيه موضوع التوهلات في المدن موضوع
هدم البيوت المتزايد بشكل كبير والاجراءات
التنكريه بحق الاسرى الفلسطينيين عبد
الحفيظ باجاز لو سمحت هل هذه الزياره
ستكون ثمارها العوده للتنسيق بين الجانب
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
ربما ربما يعني تقتنع السلطه الفلسطينيه
بان عوده التنسيق ضروره لابد منها وربما
توضع يعني عوده تنسيق بكفه واعاده الاموال
الفلسطينيه في الكفه الاخرى ربما يقتنع
الفلسطينيون بعوده تنسيق وخصوصا ان كان
هناك وعودات على الاقل بتخفيف اقتحامات
المدن والتقليل سقوط الضحايا بين
الفلسطينيين سنرى ذلك على كل حال ما يصوم
يوم غد شكرا لك عبد الحفيظ جوان وراس
العربيه من رام الله كما نشكر من القدس
ناديه البيسي مفردات العربيه على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
افادت وزاره الداخليه السوريه باصابه 15
عنصر من قوى الامن الداخلي جرى استهداف في
حافله تقلهم بعبوه ناسفه في الطريق بين
درعا ودمشق ان الاستهداف جاء خلال تنفيذ
قوى الامن الداخلي مهامها في درعا واثناء
عودتها الى دمشق فيما كشفت مصادر العربيه
السوريه مشيره الى ان ضربتين جوينتين
استهدفتان مكانا في منطقه المكمل من
الجانب السوري المصادر اضافه ان القصه كان
بالقرب من منفذ القائم الحدودي تحديدا
مخفر المحسن الذي تتواجد فيه قوته حرس
الحدود العراقيه
[موسيقى]
افضل المرصد السوريه بان عناصر موليه
للحارس الثوري الايراني اخلط مقراتها
العسكريه في مدينه البكماء شرقي دير الزور
تخوفا من ضربات المحتمله وذكر المرصد ان
هناك حاله استنفار بين صفوف عناصر الحرس
الثوري تخوفا من تكرار ضربه الجويه وذلك
بالتزامن مع تحليق الطائرات مسيره مجهوله
في اجواء منطقه
ورغمى تضاربات التي تطل اعداد الشاحنات
المستهدفه في المكالمات لكن الاجماع يتمثل
بضربه اسرائيليه اخرى ساخنه لايران خلال
اقل من 48 ساعه حيث استهدف الطائرات مسيره
قافله شاحنات في منطقه واقعه تحت السيطره
الميليشيات الايرانيه في البوكمال شرقي
سوريا بعد عبورها من العراق ولم يتضح بعد
من يقف وراء الهجوم العدد المرشح للشاحنات
المدمر سته من اصل 25 شاحنه استهدفت بثلاث
غيارات بالمسيرات والتي تقول مصادر سوريه
ان الشاحنات تحمل في الغالب اسلحه لامداد
الميليشيات ايران كونه تاثير الانفجار بعد
الدرب كان كبيره القافله كانت قادمه من
ايران مرورا من العراق بحمايه المليشيات
المواليه لايران
كحزب الله العراقي وفقا للمصادر سوريا
وعبودها حمايه الحارس السوري هناك توقفت
الشاحنات في قريه الهرب البوكمال السوريه
وهناك تم استهدافها بالمسيرات للتذكير
مشاهدينا معبر القائم يوسف الممر
الايرانيه الذي يؤدي الى سوريا ولبنان
ويشهد كف عاليه من عمليات تهذيب الاسلحه
وايضا مواد البنيه التحتيه لانتاجها
وتجميعها على الاراضي اللبنانيه والسوريه
لمتابعه ايضا ما يجري في البوكمال ينضم
الى من القاهره عبر الهاتف مدير المرصد
السوري يبدو بانه اصبح معنى مباشره رامي
عبد الرحمن مدير مرشد السوري لحقوق
الانسان رامي اهلا بك هل يمكن ان تعطينا
تفاصيل ما يجري في المكمال وكيف هو الوضع
الان قبل ان نتحدث عن موضوع اخلاء الحارس
الثوريه لمقرته هناك
نعم مساء الخير الوضع في البوكمال هناك
استنفار من قبل القوات الميليشيات ايران
حقيقه الامر قوات ايرانيه ومريشيات موالي
لها قد اخذت مقراتها خوفا من اي استهداف
من قبل الطائرات المجهوله حتى اللحظه
حقيقه الامر الى الان لا تعلم هويات
الطائرات التي استهدفت ثلاث مرات منذ مساء
الامس مناطق السيطره الايرانيه داخل
الاراضي السوريه القافله التي مرت عبر
الاراضي العراقيه نعم كانت تحمل المواد
الغذائيه ولكن هل فقد كانت تحمل وادي
غذائيه لا الشاحنات التي استهدفت كانت
تحمل السلاح الايراني الذخيره الايراني
المعدات لا نعلم ما هي ولكن بشكل القطعي
المواد الغذائيه لا تتسبب بانفجارات كبيره
بعد استهدافها من قبل الطائرات المسيره
هذه ايضا صباح اليوم كان هناك استهداف
لشخصيه من المنشات ولا الايران مع اثنين
ومرافقين كان يتفقد مكان قصف الشاحنات
وايضا بعد الظهر اليوم كان هناك استهداف
لصهريج نفاض وكان هناك تحليق للمسيرات في
سماء المنطقات هل هي المسيرات اسرائيليه
هل هي مسيرات تحالف الدولي لا لا لا ما
حقيقه الامر ولكن ما نعلمه بان يعني
شاحنات تابعه لايراج جرس اهدافها من قبل
المسيرات
بان داخل هذه الميليشيا يطلقون عليه معبر
الشهيد بين مزدوجين قاسم سليمان وهم يسمون
تلك المنطقه ايضا باسم قاسم سليمان ايران
موضوع اخلاء المقرات المقرات اخليات خوفا
من الاستهداف هي اغنيه كافه مقررات ايران
ليس في البكال في البوكمال ومحيطها جرى
اخلاؤها من قبل الميليشيات وللايران هل
الايران ستستهدف قوات التحالف الدولي داخل
الاراضي السوريه لذلك جرى خلال هذه
المقرات خوفا مرات ما قبل التحالف الدولي
لا لا اعلم ولكن ما نعلمه ايضا كان هناك
تحقيق لطائرات التحالف الدوري او بمروحيات
التحالف الدوري فوق القواعد العسكريه في
شرق الفرات شكرا لك من القاهره مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات
المعارضه التركيه تصدر وثيقه المشتركه اذا
فازت في الانتخابات عوده النظام البرلماني
وفتره رئاسيه واحده
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في باكستان تفجير
الانتحاريون في مسجد بمدينه بيشاور شمال
غربيه البلاد اسفر عن مقتل 61 شخصا واوقع
ما لا يقل عن 147 اصابه كثيرون منه في
حاله مسؤولون بالشرطه يدعى سكندر خان قال
ان المسجد كان فيه ما لا يقل عن 260 شخصا
فيما نفذ طالبان باكستان مسؤوليتها عن هذا
الهجوم
[موسيقى]
من اسلام عبادي
حفيظه اهلا بكم معنا هل هناك من معلومات
جديده عن التحقيقات خاصه بانه طالبان
باكستان نفذ ضلوعها بهذا التفجير الى من
توجه اصابع الاتهام اليوم
اه طبعا هناك يعني حسب التقرير
الاخيره
في هذه
الحادث المؤسف هذا التزايد في تزايد
والان هولي 59
قتيل
و160جريحان هيا التي نفذتها لانه هي
الاركان او جماعه واحده لها ثلاثيه
لتنفيذ
عمليه التهاميه مثل هذه
العمليه كبيره جدا
الانفجار هي منطقه حساسه فيها اجراءات
امنيه مشدده جدا كيف يمكن ان يجد من فجر
نفسه بدل انتحاري اذا ثبت ذلك ان يجد هذه
الثغره الامنيه
لكي يقوم بهذا التفجير
عمليه كبيره ولكن في نفس المكان
وهذا المسجد كانت مسجد مخصوص للمقر للشرطه
ولكن هناك ايضا
تسكنوا عائلات عائلات الشرطه في نفس
المنطقه
واغلبوا رزان بانه هذه هو جاء الى هذه
المنطقه قبل يومين
ودخل على المسجد اليوم
يعني هذه صغره ثغره كبيره ولكن حتى الان
الان
خاصه بالمؤسسات الامنيه ماذا عن وضع
الحدود مع افغانستان نحن نعلم بيشاور يعني
فقط 50 الف كيلو متر عن همم 50 كيلو متر
عن افغانستان
سعيد هناك حاله استنفار في جميع
المقررات للقوات الامن
والعيدا هناك هناك
يعني هذا التاهب ااا
ولكن اظن هذه العمليه
القوات عندنا قوات امنيه همم متمكنه
وانني
عمليه واساسيه لتصدي الارهاب واديت حركه
الطالبان الباكستانيه في الايام القادمه
يستبعد ان تقوم همم طالبان همم بهكذا
تفجير بمسجد
[موسيقى]
راينا في في الماليه ايضا مثل هذه
التذكيرات وكانت تركت التعليقات وراء هذه
التغيرات
الحركه الطالبان الباكستانيه
ليست ارقام واحده هل هناك
هناك قوادر في الحرقه
[موسيقى]
التعليمات من خارج ربما من العدول
للباكستان ليس فقط
نعم عن ايه جيران تتحدث
عن المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
اعلنت المعارضه التركيه في وثيقه رسمتها
وثيقه السياسات المشتركه اداره مرحله ما
بعد الانتخابات في حاله وصولها الى السلطه
ماذا تتضمن هذه الوثيقه اعاده النظام
البرلماني بدلا من النظام الرئاسي المعمول
به حاليا الى جانب ان تكون مده ولايه
الرئيس سبع سنوات غير قابله للتجديد كما
من المقرر ان تحصل الوثيقه السلطه اغلاق
الاحزاب السياسيه بيد البرلمان
هنا في انقره احتشدت المعارضه بعدتها
وعديدها لاطلاق برنامج عملها لمرحله ما
بعد اردوغان في حال وثق الناخبون بها
واوصلها الى السلطان
ما يعرف بالطاوله السداسيه وهي تجمع لسته
احزاب معارضه اطلقوا وثيقه السياسات
المشتركه وتتضمن خطبه عمل الوزارات
والمؤسسات الحكوميه اذا حازت صناديق
الاقتراع الى جانب المعارضه
النظام البرلماني هو كلمه السر لحل ازمات
تركيا كما يقول معارضون رئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي حاز صلاحيات واسعه في النظام
الرئاسي بناء عليه فان للرئيس الولايه
الدستوريه واحده من سبع سنوات
بصلاحيات محدوده
ضمن عمليه الاصلاح
من خلال ادخال قانون ينص على انتخاب
الرئيس لولايه واحده فقط مدتها سبع سنوات
اصلاح الاقتصاد ومكافحه التضخم هو العنوان
الثاني في خطه المعارضه كسب ودي وقلوب
الناخبين هو ما تريده الاحزاب السته عبر
وعود كثيره لتحسين دخل الفرد السنوي وخفض
معدلات البطاله وتوفير فرص عمل جديده
طيور الجنه
وننهي غلاء المعيشه مع جهودنا في مكافحه
التضخم سنزيد معدل النمو باكثر من 5%
وثيقه المعارضه تضمنت وعودا باحترام حقوق
الانسان والحريات العامه ودعم قضايا
المراه لكن هذا كله مرتبط وفق ما يراه
كثير
بالاتفاق اولا على مرشح مشترك لمنافسه
اردوغان ونبذ الخلافات التي اخر ظهور
المرشح
تحاول المعارضه الاستفاده من الوضع
الاقتصادي المتردي في برنامجها الانتخابي
لذا ركزت على اصلاحها كاهم اولوياتها
وارفق ذلك باصلاح النظام السياسي والعوده
الى النظام البرلماني وتقييد مده الرئاسه
بفتره واحده غير قابله لتجديد زيدان زينجو
العربيه انقره
[موسيقى]
الى شان اللي توفاد محامي سيف الاسلام نزل
الرئيس الليبي الاسبق معمر القذافي بتدخل
سفرتين الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده
ضد ترشح مؤكله في الانتخابات الليبيه
واتهم محامي سيف الاسلام خالد الزيدي
واشنطن بالتدخل بشكل صريح في العمليه
الانتخابيه في ليبيا كما استنكرس زيدي
موقف الجهات المسؤوله وسقوطها عن التدخل
الامريكي والبريطاني بترشح نجل القذافي
من واشنطنطينيه
سيد ربك اهلا بكم معنا الى اي حد حقيقه
الولايات المتحده او لندن يتدخلون بشان
ترشح سيف الاسلام القذافي في الانتخابات
الليبيه
لماذا هذا الاتهام
ان الولايات المتحده ولا اعلم عن المملكه
المتحده لا تعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
تتدخلوا في مساله
ترشح سيف الاسلام للانتخابات في ليبيا
اعتقد ان لعل الولايات المتحده لديها وجهه
نظر خاصه بهذا الامر
واحساسي بان الولايات المتحده ترى بانه قد
يكون مرشحا يبعث على الفرقه لكنني لا ارى
بانها تدخل وفي ذات الوقفه هي تدعم وعمليه
الامم المتحده هو مبعوثها الخاص
الذي
يدفعوا من اجل المضيء بعمليه الانتخابات
قدما والنهائي العمليه الدستوريه من اجل
الانتخابات
القذافي هو سوف الشروط هو ايضا كسب كل
الطعون التي كانت مقدمه لماذا لا تقبل به
الولايات المتحده مثلا وخاصه البعض يعتبره
بانه من الممكن ان يكون داعم لبعض الحلول
التي همم التي تتواجد الان في ليبيا والتي
يعاني منها الليبيون
عشق
اذا ما كان سوف يدعم المؤسسات الليبيه من
عدمها
متحده
الطريقه
الوطنيه
في عام 2021 وبتت بانه قادر على الترشح
ولست متاكد اذا ما صدر حكم قضائي بهذا
الامر لكن هذا الامر سوف يكون متركا
للمؤسسات الليبيه تتخذه طب لذلك اذا اا
اذا هو يعتبر بانه الولايات المتحده وحتى
بريطانيا يتدخلون همم بالهذه الانتخابات
حتى يعتبر بانه هي التي تمنع هذه
الانتخابات ااه ما الذي يعوق الان هذه
الانتخابات في ليبيا برايك
اول
واقع الامر ولا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
تتدخل فيما يتعلق بترشحه ولستوا متاكدا
لماذا محامي يقول ذلك
السياسيه التي
تقودها الامم المتحده من خلال جدول زمني
لاجراء للانتخابات ونحن في الولايات
المتحده
والحكومه في امريكا ترى بان الانتخابات
مسئلتهم ضروريه لاستقرار ليبيا
شكرا لك من واشنطين الامريكي السابق لدى
ليبيا
[موسيقى]
ليبيا ايضا قلى المجلس الاعلى لقبائل
ليبيا انه سيغلق حقول النفط والغاز بعد
اتفاق حكومه البيبا مع ايطاليا مجلس
القبائل الاكد ان اغلاقه حقول النفط في
الشرق سببه الاتفاق غير الشرعي بين
الدبيبه وايطاليا مشيرا الى ان الاحتقان
في الشارع الليبي وصل الى درجه غيري
مسبوقه
[موسيقى]
قبل ان اتوقف مع الفاصل الخارجيه الروسيه
تتحدث مستعدون للمساعده في تطويع العلاقه
بين سوريا وانقره اما نحن فسنتابع بعد هذا
الفاصل
منظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من النجاح حاله
الطوارئ عالميه وتثير القلق
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ما وصفه امل المشتركه في اعاده
بناء الروابط التي انقطعت بعد ازمه
الغواصات يجتمع وزراء دفاع وخارجيه فرنسا
واسره في باريس في لقاء ان طرفه فرنسا
فرصه لاعاده اطلاق استراتيجيتها في منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الفرنسيه عن كلاب اوضحت ان
اجتماع وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
يهدف لتوسيع الديناميكيه الايجابيه التي
بدات بعد زياره رئيس الوزراء الاستاذ
الماضي وانهارت الثقه بين باريس في سبتمبر
20 21 عندما الغي الحكومه المحافظين على
الاستراليه السابقه بشكل مفاجاه اكثر
قيمته 56 مليار لشراء غواصات من
مجموعتنافال الفرنسيه اذ فضلت الحصول على
الوسطن بريطانيا او امريكيه تعملوا
بالطاقه النوويه
[موسيقى]
اعلانات الشرطه البلجيكيه اصابه ثلاثه
اشخاص احدهم بحاله حرجه بعد هجوم بالسكين
في محطه لمترو الانفاق في حي المؤسسات
الاوروبيه في بروكسيل كم اعلنت الشرطه
انها اعتقلت المشتبه به ولا تزال تبحث في
الدوافع وقال مراسل العربيه وقعت قرب مبنى
الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسيل
[موسيقى]
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه 19 مازال يعتبر
حاله طوارئ صحيه عامه على المستوى الدولي
وقد عبرت المنظمه عن قلقها من الخطر الذي
مازال يشكله الفيروس على حياه البشر
ده كوميدي
19 لا يزال حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه وانا
اوافق على ذلك مع دخولنا العام الرابع
للوباء ليس هناك شك في اننا في وضع افضل
بكثير الان مما كنا عليه قبل عام عندما
كانت موجه ومكرون في ذروتها
[موسيقى]
ختام اخبار الساعه
معكرونه يفتحوا باب ارسال مقاتلات
لاوكرانيا بالقول انه امر غير مستبعد شرط
ان لا يضعف جيوشنا
مبعوث وامريكا الخاص لايران تقترب من
النووي وسننعها عسكريا اذا فشلت
الدبلوماسيه
الحرس الثوري الايراني
دموي كبير يستهدف مسجد في بيشاور وصلنا
باكستان تنفذ الوعها بالتفجير
[موسيقى]
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه اترككم في امان
الله
[موسيقى]